people aren't afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner you'll
record a video but you'll never release
it you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm given you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too wanna sword get a mentor
hey it's Nina Carmichael and we made
these videos probably because you're the
most ambitious person in your circle but
you know you're capable of much more and
you get that Push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan Carmichael this is everyone's
biggest fear in life and here's how to
beat it enjoy
an example was when I did my tour
90 days 23 cities and I I did a paid
tour because I was afraid to do it and
this is supposed to be a free tourist it
was supposed to be coffee shop meetups
across the U.S low res super easy one
person shows up great if nobody shows up
awesome if 100 people show up great
there's no risk right it's free you come
don't come whatever and my agent said
that's that's plain and small you got to
charge the event and my first reaction
was oh my God I can't charge this event
right like
choking up because I'm afraid because
I'm afraid that that if I start charging
for it then I need to I need to bring so
much more value
and because that was the reason then I
had to go off and do it if there was a
strategic reason why I should do a free
event then that that's fine my next tour
I'm looking at for 2020 is going to be
free is going to be ideally fingers
crossed I get my book deal it's going to
be at bookstores with my new book launch
so I want to do 20 something cities east
coast uh Texas Mexico with my book
launch and it's it's free to come
hopefully you buy a book but it's you
know not required but it's free to come
out because it's going to be supporting
the book launch that's a strategic
reason why I should be free I didn't
have a good reason why the first one
shouldn't be free what a tour this year
shouldn't be free and so I had to do it
I had to step into the fear you have to
step into the fear and do it because you
need to attack the thing that you're
afraid of especially when it's related
to other people right I'm not afraid of
failing I'm afraid of failing in front
of other people right I can suck all day
here in the office but I don't want to
suck in front of somebody else I don't
want to make people feel like whether
they're spending 50 bucks to come and
see me that was on tour or 2 000 bucks
to come see me at my thought Lucifer out
of me here I don't want people to feel
disappointed and because I feel that way
I need to step into it and I try to
teach myself attack it attack it attack
it if there's no good strategic reason
why then I have to do it because
otherwise I'm playing small and even
just attacking it for the sake of
attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they bring up couples
and they do a game show you're afraid of
what might happen on that game do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur makes you a thousand times
better as an entrepreneur because that's
the same fear that you face in your
business that fear of going on that game
show on the cruise ship that fear of
taking your phone and recording a video
in public on the street these fears that
seem like nothing they show up
everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle who cares if
you fail on the street corner making a
video great go do it if that if that is
scaring you right now do it teach
yourself you do it you have courage you
do scary things
you come out on the other side you'll
come up with more strength and then
you'll start seeing things happen in
your business
you'll have more courage you'll have
more boldness you'll be more willing to
do things and then your business starts
taking off
you have to lose the fear of failing in
front of other people I'm going to give
you three ways on how to do it step
number one is embrace your bold ideas
I'm a big believer that when you've had
these moments of boldness maybe it's
happening right now maybe you're feeling
bold right now watching the video
amazing you have these moments of
boldness we have moments of boldness I
don't think people are bold all day long
right and if you are then you have
moments of even greater boldness hear
these moments these spikes these hits
right you go to an event I look at
people coming to my thought Leadership
Academy they have these huge moments of
boldness right and then you fall back
down
and that's normal you're watching a
movie you get inspired you fall back
down you have a conversation you get
inspired you fall back down the
decisions that you make in the moments
of boldness I believe are the right ones
for you those are the decisions you have
to follow through on and embrace and
then your head talks you down from them
the head brings you back down the plane
small
and so when you're feeling bold what
have you come up with I want to go do X
you have to deal with it you have to
start building momentum you have to
start committing to some other people
embrace the Bold ideas recognize that
those aren't the crazy ideas those crazy
ideas that come up with your affiliate
world are not crazy those are actually
the best ones for you you're just buried
under pile of garbage of limited beliefs
on top of you those are the things you
have to go chase down and when it gets
hard when it gets difficult when you
want to quit remind yourself this idea
came to me when I was feeling bold I
have to do it because I do both things
you teach yourself step number two is
expect to suck this is where it gets
super liberating expect to suck the
first time you do anything expect to
suck why do you expect to be great the
first time out what do you expect your
first video that you make to be great
it's not
it'll suck that's the best it should
suck right if you are if you are amazing
and making your first video then you
should have started making videos four
years ago I believe that you waited too
long your first at anything should be
terrible doesn't mean that you suck I
think you're amazing you're a genius
you're Michael Jordan you're the best of
all time it's something
but Michael Jordan didn't didn't dunk
his first ball right he didn't he didn't
shoot and it went in right away right
you suck at the beginning that's normal
learning any skill kill you suck at the
beginning and it's really hard because
you know it looks good if you want to be
a basketball player you know what a good
basketball player looks like if you want
to be a YouTuber you know what a good
YouTube video looks like but then you
can't do it yet your first one sucks and
that's where most people quit because
they expect to be good they're worried
about looking bad in front of other
people they're not good the first time
out and so then they never go back to it
and this is what happens when when
people are are growing up you fail all
the time it's normal it's okay you fall
down awesome you get back up you keep
going and then we stop trying as adults
how often do you try new things how
often are you willing to risk failure to
risk losing to risk looking like a fool
you don't want them so you're not trying
as much anymore and you ever find the
thing you could be Michael Jordan at you
never find it and you get stuck in some
life and some job that you hate forever
that's most people I don't want that to
be you you need to try more you need to
explore more you need to expect to suck
the first 18 times of doing something
you may suck amazing keep going the most
important thing is are you liking it do
you like the process successful people
love the process I love making videos I
like this process this fires me up I'm
just sitting here by myself in my office
talking to a camera I love it this is
great I love it for other people they
may hate it amazing don't do that go do
something else go go build little Teemo
toys right awesome whoever made this who
made this
designing California oh they didn't even
they didn't give them credit all right
design in California
right go make toys go do something go to
the thing that you love expect to suck
but if you love the process of it you
will get better
think about when you whatever you
learned in school most of it you've
forgotten
but this thing that you remember the
stuff that you connected with that you
so when you love something you're gonna
just learn it a lot faster
when you like something you're going to
get better a lot faster even if you suck
at the beginning you'll get better a lot
faster you have to find that thing and
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result what I want
you to do is go home and then sleep and
think am I proud of my effort am I proud
of what I did today am I proud of the
effort that I put in today I want to be
proud of my effort today in making
videos when I'm trying my best maybe
it's not good enough maybe today sucks
awesome but I'm trying
I'm proud of my effort I'm proud of the
attempt most people tie their software
to winning to the results to the money
to the gold medal to the to the whatever
right to the YouTube to the plaques back
there
you can't do that because if you tie
yourself forth to winning
you're only going to do things that you
know you're gonna win at
and therefore you play small for life
if you value winning above everything
else
you'll only do the things that you know
you're going to win at and so you play
small for life you stop trying new
things because you're gonna fail at the
beginning right expect to suck you don't
expect to suck you expect to be great
and then you're not and so you stop
doing that thing you'll only take on
small projects but you're capable of way
more you keep doing something much
bigger
and so when you tie yourself forth to
the effort when you say I am proud of my
effort today
if you did that every day you're gonna
probably lose way more than most people
right you're going to be getting up and
losing almost every day and then you
have these big wins
but when you look back on this year of
losing you'll see holy cow how much have
I grown and you're actually winning way
more than most people way more than who
you used to be because you're part of
your effort if you get up every day and
you're part of your effort
your life will change your business will
change like every day for the next year
do something that makes you proud of
your effort in your business in your
relationship proud of your effort you
tried your very best today
your life will be dramatically different
but it's because we're so focused on
winning you're so focused on the results
but then you you play small because you
don't want to risk losing you don't want
to risk failing you're on risk looking
like an idiot
you have to if you want the life that
you're after
Michael Jordan missed more shots than
most people
you're going to fail at most things most
my videos suck and don't go anywhere
get up try again be proud of your effort
every single day rule number two go
break by break if you want to go Brick
by Brick to make to make stick you have
to pay attention to two critical pieces
the first is mindset the second is
action you need both or you're gonna
give up on your goals you know you're
capable of something bigger but you'll
give up because you don't have these two
simple things settled out I'm gonna show
you how to fix them in this video step
number one is mindset what you think
you're capable of is what you're
actually capable of if you think you can
go off and do it you're much more likely
to do it but if in your head no matter
how many skills and resources and people
are telling you you're great if in your
head you don't believe you can do it
guess what's gonna happen you're not
gonna do it and so you can apply Brick
by Brick in a methodology that I call
Big Y little y your Big Y is the big
reason why you're doing this thing why
are you doing this thing your purpose
comes to your pain you got a big goal
big ambition you want to change the
world you have to have a huge impact
right you want to solve giant problems
and change people's lives right that's
your big why you want to put a dent in
the universe right you wanna you wanna
make an impact that's beyond your
lifetime it's a huge why I'm waking up
trying to solve the world's biggest
problem I'm don't think people believe
in themselves enough I'm trying to solve
the world's biggest problem I think
that's the world's biggest problem I'm
never gonna solve it even if I touch a
billion people I'm never gonna solve it
that's
I think you should wake up and have a
big why so big that you're never going
to accomplish it you're going to climb
forever you're gonna be on your journey
forever forever forever it's the best
and oftentimes that big mission that big
Vision you have is so motivating for you
that it gets you out of bed gets you
motivated like let's go here's what I'm
trying to do and it gets you pumped up
but
sometimes the big picture is too big
sometimes your big why right is Big Y
little y sometimes the Big Y is so big
that you feel you can't do it
that you're not capable that you don't
have the skill sets that you'll never be
capable and so you throw in the towel
because it seems too big
and I get that too you know I'll look at
me and my goals of solving the world's
biggest problem and say who am I to
solve the world's biggest problem
right how how am I capable of going off
and doing that
and especially in my I'm trying to think
the last time I just thought about that
especially in my earlier years as an
entrepreneur I really struggled with
that I go do a speaking gig and and be
so fired up and so motivated like man I
know I'm crushing it I'm helping people
so much it's amazing this is this is
oxygen this is what I'm breathing is
amazing thank you so much
and then I wake up the next day and be
back to normal like oh can I do this I
don't know if I can do this because
there's lack of momentum and so that's
where the little y's come in and the
little Y is the reminder that what you
do is important I think it's I think
it's so important that you feel that the
work that you do is important
if you woke up and felt every day the
work you do matters means something it's
having an impact man the commitment
level you're gonna have is so much
greater than if you feel like nobody
cares what's the big deal meh right so
how do you remind yourself that the work
you do on a daily basis is important to
at least one person that's the little
why the big wise the big Vision big
dream big big mission like where are you
going awesome the little lie is you may
not be able to help a billion people but
you can help one
just reminding yourself that you help
one person how I get that now is in my
YouTube comments even now as part of my
morning routine I go to my YouTube
comments and I just see what people are
are saying
and these are people that you you know
amazing people who many many of whom
I've never met and maybe never will meet
hopefully hopefully I'll meet you come
on my tour meet me on tour probably I
won't meet most of you
and to see the warmth and the love and
the and the comments that you guys are
leaving makes me feel like this is why I
do it this is why it matters this work
matters if I stop doing this it would it
would mean something to people and they
you'd have to go somewhere else now not
so full of myself that you couldn't find
another solution but the work that I do
matters and your comments feed me every
day
I'm spoiled now that we get hundreds of
comments and tons of DMS and lots of
messages that come in Daily but when I
was first getting started
I didn't get that money when I talked
about my early days as a speaker I would
speak and have a great time and then the
next day wake up and feel like what's
the point I would say the thing that
made the difference was I would save the
messages that people sent me or emailed
me or said at the end of one of my
workshops and I would put them together
in a PowerPoint file and I would watch
that PowerPoint file every morning that
became part of my morning routine this
is when I really first started doing
morning routines this is this was such
an important piece for me was showing
the messages from these people as a
reminder every day that what I do makes
a difference and maybe I will never hit
my billion but these 18 people that I
helped I helped them that was me I did
that right if you felt like you helped
some people every single day even if
just remembering old people that you
helped every day as a reminder it'll
give you the ammunition the momentum the
fuel that you need to keep going every
day so Brick by Brick sometimes it's Big
Y right it's the mindset sometimes it's
the big why sometimes it's just man I'm
gonna go crush the world I'm so excited
I'm gonna go solve this giant problem
and and change Humanity right sometimes
you feel like that and it's amazing and
you go you go you use that boldness and
energy to create something amazing
and sometimes you're going to feel like
I can't do that big thing and so you
just look at the comments you look at
the the one person that you helped or
the five people that you helped or think
back the people that you have helped in
your life to remind yourself that you
are valuable that you make a difference
the work you create is Meaningful and to
get the momentum and energy you need
because for the most part the biggest
thing you're missing is just momentum
and momentum comes from mindset if you
believe you can create great things you
can so Brick by Brick starts with
mindset Big Y and little y so I said
there were two things right there's
mindset and then there's action so step
number two is action so you you think
you can do something then you have to go
off and do it thinking it is not enough
you got to do something you got to act
on it and Brick by Brick here is we
often will plan this giant thing right
you have this bold Vision this big idea
amazing and you default into planning
mode and you think I gotta do this and
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and it's
exciting and it's fulfilling it's
amazing to think in planning mode of
what you can potentially build but then
you step back and look at that Behemoth
that you just built in your head or on
paper and you think wow that's really
big
to do that I need I need venture capital
I need Partners I need I need I need a
team I need and all this all the stuff
that you need that you don't have
and then that becomes scary and then you
don't act and so I believe in what I
call the two percent difference the two
percent difference is as soon as you
come up with an idea
we're taking immediate action on the
first two percent so what we typically
do is we'll plan to get to 100 you'll
plan to 100 you'll plan your your entire
Vision out until it's complete right
then that becomes too scary instead of
planning as your first step plan is
important but it's not the first step
your first step is action your first
step is doing your first step is the
first two percent what is the first two
percent version so if you're planning is
to build the next YouTube channel it's
gonna dominate the world I love it
it's easy to think well in the camera
personally the team I need an editor and
I need a scriptwriter I need I need I
need I need anything great awesome two
percent difference take your phone make
a video today teach yourself to go from
idea to action idea to action the
smallest possible version that little
video you make from your phone what
difference is gonna make not a lot in
terms of output but a ton in terms of
momentum a ton in terms of momentum most
people just don't start if you want to
lose weight you want to get in shape the
best thing you can do is do 10 push-ups
right now I had a personal one of my
Lives who said that their goal was to to
get in shape okay great
go do 10 push-ups right now don't don't
come back on into the live until you've
done 10 push-ups are those 10 push-ups
going to actually make that person lose
20 pounds of course not
but the difference between no push-ups
and 10 push-ups is the whole game
because if they do that 10 push-ups they
taught themselves to go from idea to
action idea to action idea to action
that's the thing that's missing for most
people you have great ideas I believe
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you're not acting enough not
in a big enough way not consistently
enough there's too much time planning
and thinking and over analyzing and
worrying about judgment instead of just
getting out there and actually doing
so planning is important it's just not
the first step you burn all of your
boldness and creativity and energy on
the planning you wake up the next day
and you think I can't go do that big
scary crazy thing or instead as soon as
I get the idea the best thing you can do
with your energy with your boldness with
your confidence in that moment in that
idea that you just created is go do
something about it and teach yourself
that you're the kind of person who comes
up with great ideas who trust their
great ideas who doesn't over analyze
anymore and just puts them out into the
world and builds momentum that's going
Brick by Brick also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for the this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number three conquer fear
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of your biggest fears
you want something more you know you're
capable of something more you'll come up
with a great reason why you can't do
that something more but really you're
just afraid if you want to break through
if you want that dream life you need to
change the way you think about fear or
it will handicap you for the rest of
your life so my biggest fear is
disappointing people
I'm afraid that whatever I'm gonna do I
might disappoint somebody and that keeps
me plain small and so whenever I can
recognize it then I have to go all in
and do it just to show myself because it
allows you to play on a bigger stage
every time and that big fear you have is
still there it doesn't go away You're
Just capable of slaying a bigger dragon
each time so what used to count as
disappointing people in my fear of
disappointing people might have been
going to a coffee meeting and helping an
entrepreneur I remember one time super
clearly that I was booking a meme with
an entrepreneur and I was so worried
that I was going to disappoint her that
I was hoping that she would cancel and
the story told myself was I'm too busy I
got all the stuff to do you know the the
realistic reasons that you can convince
yourself right they weren't stupid
reasons they're realistic but deep down
was I'm just afraid I'm afraid that
she's gonna show up and I'm not going to
give her value a deep fear
and then once I went to go meet her it
was amazing I remember sitting in my car
it's like wow like an hour and a half
ago I was hoping that she was going to
cancel on me and this is the greatest
thing of all time right your biggest
fears
prevent you from living the life that
you want and so I'm afraid of
disappointing people I'm going on my
tour starting next year if you want to
join the tour there's information in the
description below we're hitting 20
something cities over almost 90 days
come see me on tour please don't let me
disappoint people
and and I'm I'm afraid I'm afraid I'm
gonna let people down I'm afraid
nobody's gonna show up we're going to be
streaming live on my YouTube channel uh
for the members for 8 to 12 hours a day
I'm afraid nobody's gonna be there it's
a constant every time I'm doing
something new and outside my comfort
zone is a constant battle that I might
disappoint people and so because I'm
afraid of that thing now I have to jump
in and do it most of the time you can't
catch I think we place it all by default
I think your greatest fear owns you and
is giving you tons of logical reasons
why I can't do that thing but whenever
you catch it whenever you do watch a
catch and say I think this is just my
fear talking
that means it's go time that means you
have to do it just to teach yourself
that you're able to conquer it and move
to a greater level of success so how do
you actually change your relationship
with fear I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is understand that
self-confidence comes from doing scary
things self-confidence self-love
self-respect comes from doing scary
difficult things if you're scared of
something right your heart's going boom
boom boom you're scared of it your word
is not going to work out and you catch
it this is the thing again 95 of the
time you'll never catch it you'll just
subconsciously play small but in the
five percent of the time that you
actually catch it
if you go off and do it even if you
don't get a result just trying just by
doing it you teach yourself that you're
awesome you teach yourself that you
don't play small it's better not to
catch it than to catch it and not do it
if you don't catch you just keep living
life right ignorance is bliss but when
you catch it say I think I'm just
actually afraid of this thing that's why
I'm not following through and then you
don't do it you're telling yourself you
suck you're telling yourself you're
afraid and when you're afraid you don't
do it I want to flip the script as soon
as you catch it in the five percent of
the cases right you catch it you have to
do it you have to do it you have to just
go off and do it because that way you're
telling yourself I'm amazing
Iraq it may not work out but I'm
crushing this fear let's go right it's a
self signal for self-respect
self-confidence self-love all of it
comes from doing scary things you love
scary things you eat scary things for
breakfast because the opposite of doing
scary things is doing things that you
know how to do which means you're bored
you're photocopying your life every day
and that's not the life that you want to
live step number two is trust your bold
ideas when you get an idea trust that it
is the right thing for you when you're
feeling bold and this doesn't happen
every day we don't wake up and say I'm
amazing
happy Thursday right that's
not how most people wake up
wake up we don't have a lot of energy
we're not feeling bold but you have
moments you have moments in your life
where you feel bold confident
Unstoppable maybe it was after meeting
maybe it was after a video maybe you got
inspired maybe you're on a walk in
meditation doesn't matter you have
moments in your life you know what I'm
talking about you've had moments in your
life where you felt inspired bold an
idea comes to you
say man if I could do that it'd be
amazing right you know what I'm talking
about
and then the next day you wake up so I
can't do that that crazy thing who am I
I can't do that I don't have the XYZ
right the money connections time
resources blah blah blah blah blah I
can't do that
right
trust your bold ideas I believe that the
ideas that come to me that come to you
when you're feeling bold are actually
the right ones for you
and then your brain which is designed to
keep you safe and only understands the
world that currently exists your brain
starts talking you down from it and if
you wait till the next day it's over
then your brain is already taking charge
it's in control again you're back to
being safe boring photocopy your life
over and over and over again
so trust your bold ideas when you're
feeling bold an idea comes to you say
this is right for me and then take some
immediate action towards it it'll make a
huge difference and then step number
three is Your Bucket List is your excuse
list this might be a little more
controversial but I think I think when
people add something to their bucket
list I think it's an excuse list I think
most people die with a Bucket List full
of ideas
just because you call it a bucket list
doesn't mean it's going to get done
as soon this is what you want to train
yourself as soon as you put something on
your bucket list go do it
find the smallest boss away and start
building it right that experience that
you want you could go off and do it and
teach yourself that you're the kind of
person who comes up with bold ideas and
starts immediately taking action not in
five years when I when I'm XYZ then I'm
gonna do it that's garbage that's that's
loser thinking you might think you're
crushing it by having this bucket list
of dreams and goals you're not you're
teaching yourself that you suck at least
I think that
because you're teaching yourself you
make a list of ideas and then you don't
follow through the best thing you want
to cause a guy who came to my event in
Phoenix he said well my goal on my
bucket list is I want to I want to climb
Mount Everest
okay great go do it even just believing
that that's possible in the next year
instead of waiting 20 years for that
thing to happen right already changes
your mindset you could do it what do you
need you need money you need training
you need resources what figure it out
you could figure it out if that really
was so important to you
if that really was so important to you
you could do it in the next year you
could
and if it's not that important to you
why is it on your bucket list in the
first place
people die with their Bucket List full
your bucket list is your useless instead
start making an action list and get to
work rule number four be productive what
matters is that you're productive that
you get results that you stop wasting
time too many people default to thinking
that if they just wake up an hour
earlier they're going to be way more
productive if you're not productive in a
16 hour day what makes you think that
you're gonna be more productive in a
17-hour day when you have less sleep so
this is a interesting message in timing
for me right now because I I love
beating the Sun up I love it I I love
working I like it's my default state of
Nina is off on a Friday night with her
friends or something 80 chance I'm
working I love it I look forward to it
when I go close my eyes I can't wait for
it to be the next day like I'm pumped to
go off and do the work
I recently did a sleep study and my
doctor was concerned I wasn't getting
enough quality sleep so I wanted to do a
sleep study and the doctor after going
through the results told me that I need
to be sleeping eight and a half hours to
nine hours a night
and it and it like
super disappointed me eight and a half
hours to nine hours are you kidding me I
I'm trying to go from I was trying to go
from eight to seven I was waking up
after eight hours sleep and and feeling
still a little bit tired and so that's
why my doctor recommended even going to
the sleep study and I'm trying to figure
out how do I hack it to get down to
seven and still be fully functional not
not be you know lazy and slow and not
having my cognition and uh yeah he said
I need to be sleeping eight and a half
to nine hours a night he said is that is
that normal like are you not worried
like no as long as you're under 10 it's
normal people range from six to ten and
they're totally fine like this sucks I
mean I'm not happy about it I'm still
looking at how can I hack my sleep more
and we've tried a lot I have the chili
pad we've got you know meditation before
sleeping I'm lying on the bed of nails
with the thing behind me the pillow the
nail pillow uh no you know phones or
computers x amount of time before going
to bed red light filters on everything
red lights no lights at all in the place
right like just these real red lights
glowing around after Sunrise after
Sunset lots of it cool down the
temperature I don't know all of it don't
eat past eight o'clock no caffeine past
two o'clock all of it I'm doing all of
that stuff all of it right plus probably
a lot more stuff I've I've studied and
hacked away I still believe there's a
lot more hacking I still want to get it
from nine to seven but but if I'm at
nine and I need nine I think you should
get nine I'm at the point now where if I
wake up and the Sun is still uh not up I
stay in bed and and that's actually uh
boosting of confidence it's like okay so
I wake up and sun is hasn't come up yet
okay this is hard this is difficult it's
difficult for me to not get out of bed
I'm gonna stay in bed just because guys
now I'm I'm a I'm a weird duck so maybe
this works for you maybe it doesn't but
I was having a great conversation with
Jeremy who's on my team who who I've
invested in his business he's helping
companies scale their YouTube channels
and he was going through the same thing
where he was feeling a little tired in
the afternoon he wanted to nap on some
afternoons and that's never been me so
dude you need to just try uh waking up
without an alarm
and he normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something
um so just wake up without an alarm and
see how it goes and he ended up sleeping
for nine hours and Hayden hating himself
for doing it it's like dude maybe you
need nine hours like much more important
than that extra hour or two is what are
you doing during the day if if you're
losing energy during the day and you
want to nap every afternoon you're not
being productive like there's no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win I think everybody should get a
sleep test I think it's a brutal
experience you don't you barely sleep
right when you're there you got to stuff
up your nose and a million sensors all
over you but to know how much sleep you
actually need and making sure that
you're productive during the time that
you are awake that's the most important
thing that you are productive during the
time that you are awake is way more
important than if you wake up before the
sun gets up okay so how can you do it
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is fix your calendar
fix your calendar you got to make sure
that you're productive make sure that
your action is mapped to your Ambitions
the reason why so many people say wake
up early is because your evening hours
for many people are not productive
because when you wake up you're more
likely to be productive and you're gonna
you're gonna do your work you're gonna
get more routine you're gonna feel like
you got a kick start on the day you're
going to go off and start to crush it
where if you're staying up late at night
you're going to find yourself playing
games or watching Netflix or doing
things that aren't productive right like
waking hours make sure you're productive
put it in your calendar you're waking up
around this time right how are you going
to spend your morning routine what does
that look like and then what are you
gonna do and mapping it out so that when
you can step above your calendar and
look at the week and the month that's
ahead you say if I did these things
that's in my calendar I'm going to be
more successful I'm going to be closing
in on my goals right your actions map to
your Ambitions so you create your
calendar
and then you go and live it and then you
go and do it the most important thing
again isn't making sure you're up before
the sun it's making sure that you're
doing the things that you said you were
going to do and the things that you said
you were going to do are going to lead
you to accomplishing the success that
you want to have you have to be more
productive and fix your calendar step
number two is understand how much sleep
you actually need right I I've heard it
I guess before but I didn't really buy
it until I went and did the sleep study
and again I'm still trying to hack it I
still believe I can get it lower even if
I go from nine to eight that's amazing
but I have to be fully refreshed I have
to be ready to start my day and so
understand how much sleep you need right
here's a challenge for tomorrow don't
set an alarm
and see what time you wake up and if and
you sleep an extra hour and you feel
more refreshed like you're probably
living in a massive sleep deficit for
you
and so maybe you need seven hours or
maybe you need eight hours or maybe you
need nine hours and if you need a lot
more than that then maybe you know
there's a problem you gotta go get it
fixed I was hoping that you could give
me uh like if I had sleep apnea amazing
my problem is take me awesome give me
the machine I'll sleep with every night
I'll sleep seven hours and I'll go and
crush it like no you don't have sleep
apnea you don't you don't have any
deficiencies I did a bunch of blood
tests no deficiencies there's nothing
actually wrong with you you just need
nine hours sleep
[Music]
it just tears me apart but you have to
figure out how much sleep you need
because again sacrificing one hour of
sleep
and being tired all day is not going to
make you more productive understand how
much sleep you need and then factor that
into your calendar factor that into your
life so you can be happy you can be
fulfilled you could have energy you can
go and crush your goals and then step
number three is work to your rhythm
some people work better at night than
they do during the day right again as I
said earlier the reason why so many
people advocate for a morning start is
because at night most people aren't
productive at night you're losing time
at night you're watching Netflix and
playing games and doing things that
aren't in supportive of your mission
right listen to Grant though he goes to
sleep at nine
don't go to sleep at nine and he wakes
up before the sun comes up he's getting
enough sleep to do it right but your
best productivity might be at nine like
maybe you don't even turn on until nine
maybe you should be working from nine
until four in the morning
right work to your style because if you
try to be somebody else and you try to
work to a different style that's not
suited for you you're not going to win
it's more difficult if you're working
from nine you know P.M to 4 a.m how many
hours is that
10 11 12. that's seven hours right if
you're working from nine to five the
other way
uh that's gonna be hard to do meetings
that's gonna be hard to have Team calls
it's going to be hard to scale up your
business right it'll be difficult
because most people don't want to work
for a midnight meeting with you but if
that's where you are your most creative
and that's where you get the most
productivity out of you then you need to
factor that in if you're more of an at
night owl and you're gonna work every
night you're gonna move forward on your
Ambitions every night
then don't beat yourself up because you
didn't get up before the song came up
rule number five the last one before our
very special bonus clip celebrate
yourself more your brain is keeping you
afraid and preventing you from achieving
everything that you want because your
brain is practical it's logical it only
understands a world that currently
exists and if you want to change the
world and you don't learn how to hack
your brain you are going to play scared
for life so I was trying to think about
as I was watching this video what the
when was the last time that I felt
really overwhelmingly scared like I
might not be able to do this I can't do
this I'm not capable I'm not worthy I
don't think I I'm gonna deliver a good
job
and the the only idea that came to mind
recently of a big thing was when I was
speaking at the event in Phoenix and I
was invited by Brendan burchard and Dean
grazioc and I was speaking of their
event and before me was Eric Thomas on
day one and I was the last speaker on
the last day and I remember the day of I
was pacing backstage about an hour 45
minutes before the actual event I'm I'm
there I'm pacing I'm walking back and
forth Brendan burchard said he's gonna
watch my entire speech and give me
feedback after which only adds to the
pressure and there was a moment where I
blanked out there was a moment maybe 10
minutes before I went on stage I'm
standing backstage and I blank out I
blank like I don't I don't even know
what I'm going to talk what am I going
to talk about right now I don't even
know what I'm going to talk about right
now it's been a long time since I felt
that level of
desperation insecurity overwhelm because
usually as soon as something as soon as
I hear myself saying this is hard this
is difficult uh I said okay let's go do
it the challenge in this situation was I
couldn't just get up on stage whenever I
wanted
and so I'm I'm left sitting there
walking backstage thinking oh my God oh
my God oh my God what if I don't win
what if I don't what if I don't give a
great performance what if I let
everybody down which is my greatest fear
what if I let the audience down and
Brendan down and Dean down and I totally
I just forgot what I'm gonna say how do
I even start my presentation I'm gonna
wake I'm gonna I'm gonna get up on stage
and just face plant
it was this
I don't know minute of just real
desperation
of feeling like oh my gosh I'm gonna get
up there and suck
I don't know what I'm gonna say
and then the thing that caught me
so grateful that it takes like the
training the training this is how you
train yourself the training came in
I said what are you doing you're Evan
Carmichael
let's go
and that may sound super egotistical
but I think I think the self-criticism
only works when it's based off a
foundation of self-love like I think you
need to celebrate yourself more I think
you need to recognize yourself more not
bragging on social media that you did
some fake goal that you know didn't take
a lot of work but you might get some
accolades for from your friends and
people following you I'm talking about
what do you tell yourself like when you
walk past yourself in the mirror do you
see a rock star do you see a stud do you
see somebody who's gonna go change the
world most people is no and it's and if
it's a yes it's not consistent and so I
think doing the work to tell yourself
that you're amazing I think that should
be a default answer every time you're
nervous is to say I'm fill in your name
I'm you your name right
I'm Evan Carmichael let's go
and that motivated me to then instantly
remember what the thing was it wasn't
that I forgot what I was going to say I
was just too stressed out and blocked
that I couldn't actually get through to
what I was supposed to go out and talk
about and so that shift in my state
um by telling myself I'm Evan Carmichael
let's go
allowed me to connect to it and then go
off and deliver
um at least what I thought was a pretty
great speech and event so how can you do
it for you how can you hack your brain
I've got a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is scary
difficult or hard
this is where I might have a different
strategy compared to Marissa peer she
says when you're feeling nervous tell
yourself that you're excited and because
it's the same emotions because you're
you're sweaty your palms are you know
sweaty your your speech is elevated your
heart rate's going faster right the the
signs of being nervous and excited are
the same so so trick your brain by
saying you're excited instead of nervous
I actually don't like that and and lots
of people say that Simon Sonic says that
Marissa Pierce says as a bunch of people
say that
I like to tell myself I do things that
make me nervous right scary difficult
harder usually the three but let's add
nervous as a fourth scary difficult hard
and nervous
that is not an acceptable reason for you
not to take action because you do scary
difficult hard and nervous you love
scary difficult hard and nervous because
the other side of scary difficult heart
and nervous the opposite is what is
comfort is complacency is boring is
photocopying your day over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again you don't want
that
the opposite of nervous is boring
it's boring the opposite of nervous is
not excited the opposite of nervous is
boring the opposite of nervous is you
hate your life if there's nothing in
your calendar in the next month that
makes you nervous that is scary
difficult to hard you hate your life and
most people are so busy running away
from the things that make them feel
nervous because it's too scary difficult
or hard and then they they know that
they're capable of great things but they
never do it it's unrealized potential
but you know you're capable of more it's
not ignorance is bliss you know you're
capable of more and you're not doing it
because you're afraid watch your
language right whenever you say scary
difficult to hard that means it's go
time that means you have to do it just
because because you love scary difficult
and hard and ask your friends and your
family and the people around you to
catch it anytime you say scary difficult
or hard
tell them to call you out on it now they
may say what are you talking about
you're you're always the one going off
and doing scary difficult hard things
don't buy into that they just have lower
standards than you do
ask them to catch you on because you are
you are doing it you are making mistakes
you are saying that to yourself and if
it ever comes out of your voice if it
ever comes through your head then you
have to go up and do that thing just to
show yourself that you can step number
two is the boom boom test and that's
that's when your heart's going boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom again that's go
time the first one scary difficult hard
and nervous is is words right it's
vocabulary it's it's you hear yourself
thinking it or you actually say it out
loud
for some of you might be more physical
which is when you feel your heart going
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom you
might not be even thinking something
properly you might not even have words
in your head because you're so nervous
right but when you feel your heart going
like this that means it's go time too
especially when it's because of somebody
else's potential opinion if you're going
boom boom boom because of fear of
judgment
then you have to do it again just
because not not worrying about if it
works out or not but just to show
yourself that you can do it because
whenever you play small based off of
somebody else's opinion of you you're
telling yourself that you suck you want
to do something you're afraid of how
you're going to judge for it so you
don't do it I suck
that's how it works you're telling
yourself that you suck every time that
you don't follow through on the thing
you want to do because you're worried
that somebody else is going to judge you
we're not afraid of failing don't fool
yourself it's not that you're afraid of
failing you're afraid of failing in
front of somebody else you will sing in
the shower but you won't sing on the
street corner why because you're afraid
of public failure you're afraid of
failing in front of somebody else
and that's what you need to destroy so
when your heart's going boom boom boom
boom boom let's go and step number three
is trust your bold ideas trust your bold
ideas I believe the idea was given for a
reason
what did the idea come
somewhere it's flowing through you know
you nothing do it I believe that the
ideas that come to you when you're
feeling bold unsolvable powerful
confident those ideas are actually the
best ones for you and then your brain
talks you down from doing them that's
why the most important first step is
momentum the biggest thing missing in
your life is momentum as soon as you get
an idea do something about it stop
planning stop thinking stop being
perfect stop worrying about other
people's opinions stop researching
because you're going to be bold and
using all of your best bold Creative
Energy on planning thinking researching
and then you wake up tomorrow and your
brain takes over again tells you you
can't do it
and then what happens you don't
instead use that first moment when
you're feeling the Bold energy The
Confident moment you come up with an
idea immediate action momentum instantly
you do that you'll change your life
if you want to be a successful
entrepreneur you're going to have to
deal with a lot of pain there will be a
moment when you feel like things just
can't get any worse you're at the bottom
and then pow life hits you in the face
and that moment will Define you either
you're gonna quit and give up go back to
having a job or you're going to learn to
rise above and start having success as
an entrepreneur the strategy that I like
to use is it's the best you take
whatever negative situation you're in
whatever that thing that feels
overwhelming all-consuming impossible to
deal with and you tell yourself this is
the best this thing is happening to me
right now is the best this is my chance
to show myself and the world what I'm
made of it's the best and in actuality
it is the best because we very rarely
get chances to show ourselves what we're
made of we very rarely actually put
ourselves into these situations where we
get hit in the face
I broke my neck right I broke my neck in
Colorado we would normally wouldn't put
ourselves in these kinds of situations
where you break your neck and you have
to put staples in your head and you have
a concussion like we don't do that to
ourselves but when it happens it's the
best this is the best I love this I'm
thinking of doing a tour in 2020 around
the new book launch East Coast in Texas
maybe northern Mexico
it's not going to be as good
it's like pushing through the not even
just the people who are dming me and
saying Heaven this is so inspiring I
can't believe you're still going I was
complaining about being tired this
morning and I saw you making videos with
your broken neck and realized I have no
excuse like all of that is amazing but
it's for myself it's a show myself what
I'm made of this is the best like I
really think that looking back
in 10 years like from 10 years from now
looking back on what's happening right
now in the pushing through in the still
making videos in the finishing my tour
and then not quitting and going home
even though everybody would understand
like this is actually the best I think
that I'm even though I'm telling myself
it's the best this is actually an
understatement compared to how much it
will be the best
because in 10 years they're going to
look back and say holy cow that was
crazy
I can't believe we did that that was
nuts that's how you build self-respect
that's how you build self-confidence and
self-love by doing difficult things and
being proud of your effort now I haven't
been a hundred percent I had to cancel
my event in Denver because I was in the
hospital my next event was Kansas City
and I had to refund everybody the money
but I still showed up and said hey I'll
do this for an hour and I actually went
for an hour and a half but it wasn't the
full three hours and so I didn't charge
them for it
it wasn't my best performance compared
to If I Didn't Have a broken neck right
but it's actually the best
and so when you can flip your thinking
what it does is it it puts you in a
state of resourcefulness when you get
hit with an adversity and it's hard
right you get hit with something that
sucks
right when you get hit with that and
you're overwhelmed by it and say this
sucks this can't I can't believe I can't
believe this has happened to me why me
which is most of America right what most
people will say
you've lost you've just lost and and
it's compounded by everybody say no it's
okay don't worry you should quit you
should give up stop it's don't worry
about it everybody understands you feel
worse
but if you can rise up and say this is
the best it puts you in a state of
resourcefulness
it makes you feel like you can do it
when everybody's telling you to stop and
you keep going because of this adversity
that's hit you that's
that's actually the best
and so it's about being proud of
yourself
right now I couldn't do the event in
Denver I couldn't do the full event in
Kansas City did I did I complete my
objective no right did I follow through
100 no but I'm proud of myself in all of
this I want you to be proud of yourself
are you proud of yourself
if every night you went to sleep
put your head on a pillow and said I did
I'm I'm proud of myself today like the
work I did I'm PR I mean I've gotten the
result it may not have been perfect I
may have still let somebody down I may
still have lost money but I'm I'm proud
of myself for what I did your effort
and so it might seem a little weird duck
maybe maybe you'll have to watch a video
a couple times or hear it repeating a
few other videos but try it as an as an
experiment the next time you're faced
with something overwhelming impossible
negative I can't believe this why me why
is this happening next time you find
yourself thinking those things
try to flip the script
try to catch it and say this is the
[Music]
because you made it this far in the
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome and if you want to watch Evan's
top 10 rules for Success check out the
video next to me I think you can enjoy
continue typically I will see you there
had an upper class today best way I
found is you create a calendar so you
create a calendar and you put in your
calendar the habits that will lead you
towards success right so you have ideas
for what you want to create amazing